hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 english language norwegian fantasy
and thriller movie called mortal
the movie begins with eric bergland an
american norwegian who has no purpose in
his life and is wandering around the
woods of norway with his wounded leg
after a long journey he decides to build
a tent in the middle of the forest and
rest there for a night that night while
sleeping eric suddenly becomes
emotionally unstable and somehow the
trees outside the tent start burning
in the morning every tree around him has
been burnt down but eric and his tent
remain unharmed
however the burn wound on his leg is
getting worse and he decides to head
over to the town nearby
upon arrival he goes into a clinic and
steals several things to heal his wound
while treating his wound he realizes
that he looks awful thus he trims his
hair and transforms into a much better
looking guy
on his way to nowhere free troublemaker
teens with their dad's mercedes spot him
and attempt to talk to him but eric
ignores them one of them hole is unhappy
with him and starts harassing the
homeless man
eric warns old not to touch him again or
he will be burned but the cocky teen
ignores the warning and grabs his jacket
ol suddenly collapses and dies instantly
without having eric to touch him eric
runs off and is subsequently arrested by
the local police for murder
the next day while he awaits extradition
back to the united states the local
police chief henrik brings in a
psychologist called christine hoping
that she can make eric talk henrik tells
her that the man is also a suspect in an
unsolved fire incident at a farm that
killed five people three years ago
at first eric who is sitting at the
corner of the interrogation room refuses
to talk to her
somehow christine manages to convince
him to sit at the table where she calms
him down telling him that it was not his
fault and bad things happen
to gain eric's trust she suggests henrik
who is watching from the other room to
have his handcuffs removed
a few moments later ola's parents arrive
at the police station and his dad bjorn
insists to see the murderer but henrik
rejects the request
after that eric finally admits that he
killed the people at the farm who turn
out to be his relatives
as they speak he demonstrates his
superpower pulling the water up from a
glass
christine is confused and asks for an
explanation but eric also doesn't
understand how that happens
furthermore he manages to burn the table
just by using his hand
eric suddenly gets emotional again and
starts burning the whole interrogation
room christine concludes that his
emotions control his power thus she
approaches eric and quickly counsels him
on how to focus to control his power he
eventually manages to control his
emotions and stop the chaos
not long after the u.s embassy's officer
hathaway arrives to bring eric back to
america
he refuses to talk to anyone other than
christine
she warns them not to take eric with a
helicopter because it is too dangerous
they insist and because of that eric is
sedated to keep him unconscious during
the flight
eric suddenly awakens in the middle of
the flight and starts to panic from
being tied up the doctor cannot give him
another dose because he will overdose
eric somehow creates a thunderstorm
which causes the helicopter to lose
power and crash into the sea
he then realizes that he can breathe in
the water and uses his power to burn the
seatbelt he manages to save hathaway and
immediately runs away after she awakens
the search and rescue team begins the
search operation in the wreckage and is
able to identify three dead bodies on
the other side christine sees the news
about the helicopter crash and
immediately rushes to the scene eric
suddenly shows up in front of the
psychologist's house and she decides to
bring him to her friend's cabin in the
middle of the forest he reveals that he
receives the power at the farm and
explains that the fire incident at the
farm was caused by him bursting into
flames
at the hospital hathaway shows henrik of
proof that reveals eric's ability to
control the weather that caused the
helicopter crash
because of that she tells the police
that they need to find him as soon as
possible the next day christine receives
a call from her friend telling her that
she is hiding a criminal and suggesting
her to turn eric into the police
after eric wakes up she explains the
suggestion to eric and apologizes before
they depart christine suddenly hugs the
superhuman and realizes that she has
feelings towards him she changes her
mind and decides that she must take eric
back to the farm to understand the
origin of the power
her friend and henrik keep calling
christine so she decides to throw her
phone away to the water in the gas
station christine learns that the police
are looking for eric because he has
become the suspect and is responsible
for the helicopter crash
while on their way eric's explains that
he sometimes feels as if he is in a
different world where he sees an
enormous tree that fills the entire
horizon
a few moments later christine attempts
to overtake a big truck in front of her
because of that their car almost
collides with a car that is running in
the opposite direction
this makes eric panic and suddenly emits
a thunderbolt that destroys their car
but somehow it doesn't harm christine at
all after crashing the truck driver
decides to give them a ride
not long after the police arrive at the
crash scene where hathaway states that
eric isn't allowed to reach and get
through a bridge that will lead him to
the other city they eventually reach the
bridge that the u.s agent mentioned
earlier however the police have set up a
roadblock
the driver finally realizes that eric is
the man the police have been looking for
and immediately stops the truck they
then have no option other than to
surrender eric gets out of the truck and
turns himself in while two police
officers keep pointing their gun at him
christine approaches them and asks them
to lower their weapons but they capture
her instead
eric begs them to release his lover but
they ignore him causing eric to rage and
lose control the dark clouds suddenly
cover the sky and the thunderstorm
occurs
thunderbolts begins to strike while eric
is screaming in agony as usual christine
approaches him and tells him to control
his emotions the police officers keep
walking towards them and then eric uses
his power to create a lightning fence
until he collapses and the storm
subsides
henrik comes to help and immediately
rushes both of them to the hospital eric
and the bridge incident has become viral
and the local people start to believe
that he is a god
some of them even claim that he is thor
upon arrival the wounds on his body are
getting worse and he is directly brought
to the mri scanner
christine tries to keep him calm through
headphones
however when the scanning process begins
eric accidentally destroys the machine
with his power and causes a power outage
at the hospital to make things worse a
nurse appears saying that a boy has gone
into cardiac arrest and needs a direct
treatment eric immediately rushes
towards the icu when bjorn ola's dad
suddenly shows up and shoots him luckily
henrik manages to calm him down and he
eventually lets eric proceed to the icu
using his power eric revives the boy and
he wakes up from his coma making his
parents cry tears of joy
since then eric has become popular and a
lot of people beg him to hold their hand
they then continue their journey to the
farm
on their way henrik hands over a norse
mythology book to christine
he explains that after thor and other
gods died in ragnarok thor's children
built a farm and they believe it is the
same farm where eric gained his power
upon arrival henrik and the psychologist
explore the place while eric is ordered
to wait at the entrance he follows them
and they then come across a rune where
eric is brought to his knees and unable
to move
henrik believes that something is hidden
down there and immediately orders his
men to dig the place
on the other side hathaway and the us
army arrive and secretly monitor what
they are doing waiting for the right
time to kill eric the team eventually
finds a cave under the farm where a lot
of ancient norse runestones they even
discover a depiction of yggdrasil the
trees eric talked about earlier to
christine
after the team examines the place eric
is told it is time for him to go into
the cave where he comes across a chest
with one of the team members help he
opens the chest and discovers thor's
glove his belt and his hammer mjolnir
eric then grabs them and wears all the
thor's equipment and suddenly a
thunderbolt strikes from the sky but
this time it doesn't harm his body as
the hammer absorbs all the energy
he comes out from the cave and christine
immediately approaches him meanwhile
hathaway orders her sniper to
assassinate eric but the bullet misses
and hits christine instead killing her
instantly eric desperately tries to
revive her but he fails eric becomes
enraged and uses the hammer to create a
massive thunderstorm ruthlessly
attacking people nearby the farm
at the end of the movie a reporter
states that the thunderstorm at the farm
has caused a large number of casualties
and eric mysteriously disappeared
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching